let's play more nutrition truths that
Wellness influencers don't want you to
know putting oat milk in your coffee
isn't going to cause diabetes let the
people have their damn coffee the way
they like it sweet potatoes aren't a
superfood and white potatoes aren't junk
food nutritionally they're really
similar except this one's massive
processed foods aren't all bad frozen
veg for example are processed and in
many cases are healthier than fresh
Bagels aren't the equivalent of like six
slices of bread you don't have to hollow
them out if you don't want to
the blood type diet is bloody BS blood
type oat can have avocados and blood
type A can have berries chlorophyll
water won't detox your body or make you
lose weight it just tastes gross
a core diet doesn't cure IBS you're less
bloated because you've just removed a
ton of foods
which of these nutrition truths are
going to make the most people mad let me
know below